hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday October 9th
2023 2023 I am back home my tour is
[__]
over um I had a great time on it but
before I get into that before I get into
that what the [__] happened to my
Patriots
yesterday Jesus
Christ 34 to nothing at home against the
[__] Saints the David carled Saints
David the new kid on the
Block via [__] Oakland in Las
Vegas you
know you figured he'd go down there and
be like Oh my God look at all these
beautiful women you know he's out he's
not he's not being dumb he's not on
Bourbon Street but you know he's out
there he's getting a lay of the land
right Alvin kamaro all I just I look
hats off to the [__] Saints but I
gotta tell you something man our [__]
defense dude there was a couple of times
like guys just like not only do they
take bad angles they just like just and
then just sort of ran away from the play
it was just a
complete [__] disaster
from the beginning to the end I mean all
I just kept thinking at the end of the
game was that classic we didn't do
diddly
poo our offense sucked our defense
sucked we couldn't get a first down we
couldn't
tackle
um I don't know well I guess I got a
long season ahead of me
um I kind of thought last week I was
like all right we need to M Jones needs
time
okay and uh you know or whatever I don't
know we we need or we need a combination
of a better offensive line and maybe
give somebody else a shot at at
quarterback I don't [__] know but I
can tell you after this week I I don't
know what we
need um that was a Chicago Bear level
[__] performance before their
Thursday night game congratulations to
them
and whoever that wide receiver was i'
already you know I'm old I forget
people's names [__] guy had
240 yards receiving um that was great I
was very happy for the Bears and
also you know in
honor of Dick buttkiss
passing that's a biggie man that is a
biggie uh him passing
um in honor of him I I think that they
went out and and played their best game
in a long time
and
uh it's just a shame
that you
know I don't know the last 16 games of
his life he had to watch him [__]
lose but you know he played on some
tough teams too I think or he saw it
before Walter pton got there I don't
know whatever whatever rest his
soul um so anyway I'm still in Milwaukee
right now I'm just saying I'm back home
because by the time you hear this I will
be back home or on my way I'm on my
way
um I got the [__] Kansas City Chiefs
Minnesota Vikings game on um it's kind
of a weird year man every time I start
to think I know who people
are just [__] weird man in other
words I'm getting my [__] ass kicked
this week I think I'm 0 and2 at this
point I had the Ravens and I had the
Patriots getting one at home and I was
like all right he's got a nice defense
that bill bellich he'll confuse the [__]
out of David our [__] defense looked
like melted [__]
butter I refuse to believe that we're
this bad of a football team I just I
don't know what happened but we just got
our [__] Fanny
spanked
um
anyway oh no what the [__] happened to
Kelsey is he
hurt Jesus Christ dude Kelsey just went
down on that [__] play that looked
like me when I threw up my back opening
the [__] Frieza he turned his
ankle y you know I'm telling you he
starts dating that [__] model and he
can't stay healthy right or whatever she
is pop star that's what people going to
say um
anyway let's get to talking about the
tour I'm trying to think where the hell
I was since the last time I talked to
you I'm just going to pick it up and
we'll say
Syracuse right I was in Syracuse and I
went to this place to get coffee the oh
I already talked about that so it was
after that I did Penn
State right did I just talk about Penn
State yet when the [__] was pen I don't
know people at some point I did Penn
State and I walked to
campus I think I talked about that I
think it's after that then we went up to
Niagara Falls which I hadn't been to
since I was a kid
like like 40 [__] years ago and I
went on stage in Niagara Falls and I
don't know what happened I started
riffing and I never stopped I think I
did about maybe 10 minutes of my ACT 15
minutes of my act and did about
uh an hour and 10 an hour and 15 minutes
um it was funny the bus drive I got a
really good compliment from him he goes
how the he's like how do you do that I
just laughed like dude I've been doing
this a long time this is called avoiding
your act when you have a bunch of gigs
in a row you can't be doing your act
every night or you're going to burn it
out and you're going to want to kill
yourself and you know Niagara Falls is
right there it is a viable
option do you know they said like
uh I don't want to say it cu the cops
say well we don't really publicize it
but uh let's just say uh you know
it's not the most unique
idea ah [__] it people are doing it
anyways they [__]
um look at Travis Kelce now he's [__]
hurt he's dating this [__] rockar he
grew a Freddy Mercury mustache is his
his his [__] brain isn't on the
game that's what people will say like
turning up Ah that's out of bounds right
there not a catch
um so they say like they average like 20
to 30 people a year [__] go over the
falls either by accident on on or on
purpose and I was talking to the cop and
he's going yeah he goes we find him in
the spring they start coming
up so they got to go down there and fish
people out I mean what the [__] it has
to be like that has to be so [__]
surreal
you know when you're going over the
falls like I mean it's pretty [__]
iconic I mean if you're gonna do
it
right Golden Gate Bridge Niagara Falls
Grand
Canyon I mean I don't
know
um it's pretty [__] I can't imagine
but but I don't know it seems like if
you go over on the American side like
you have no shot of living because
there's just rocks and [__] down there
uh but if you go over the other the
Canadian side you know Canadians they're
evidently supposed to be nicer even the
Horseshoe was nicer you know doesn't
seem to be a lot of rocks there there
was some guy who went over and he didn't
die and they [__] went down there we
was just sitting on some rocks next to
the waterfall just [__] sitting
there like what are you
doing I can't imagine that like cuz a
lot of this is the thing why you don't
want to kill yourself cuz I watch watch
that Golden Gate Bridge
one
um and everybody who like survived they
all the same thought the second they let
go they were like why did I do that you
know and whatever problem you're going
through it's you're going to get past
it's just a funny [__] story you're
going to tell later when your life gets
better you know or you go over the nagra
falls I mean come on what are you doing
right I can't imagine though you go over
the
falls you [__] don't die and you're
like Jesus Christ I can't [__] do
anything right and then you're just
sitting down there and you're like well
now now what the [__] do I do or maybe
you're thinking as you're going over the
falls like why did I do this you know
what if this is the year the Leafs
finally win the cup and I [__] miss
it right you go over the
falls and then you live you're like oh
thank God you know maybe they have a
balanced attack this year maybe they're
gonna [__] win
it I don't
know here's something that's weird to me
you know you never see a business called
Hitlers right you never meet anybody
called Adolf you never see a business
called Hitlers that was all Fade Out
phased out but there's still an oil
company called Hess you know oh [__]
Rudolph hes slipped through the goddamn
crack um I don't know sorry I've been I
just been looking at [__] on the
internet I don't I don't know what what
I don't know what you want from me but
um I've been playing drums every single
night which has been
uh which has been really amazing and
uh you know after I did uh Niagara
Falls which I think was one of my one of
my favorite memories of this trip
was I was hanging with Nate Craig and he
goes hey you want to get a gelato and
I'm like I don't eat dessert I don't
[__] with that [__] I've been eating
really good right and uh
um he goes come on man he goes a gelato
and an espresso and I was like all right
[__] it and we were sitting
outside the uh the casino we were just
looking at you know them advertising the
shows and just eating I got pistachio
gelato and I had this espresso and it
was [__] amazing and then we were
laughing because there was a a a prince
cover band
coming to town and we were like Griffin
on it saying oh Prince is here p r i n
[Laughter]
TS um but I saw Paul Anka Paul Anka is
coming to Niagara Falls everybody and
I'm GNA tell you something right now do
not miss that guy he absolutely destroys
and he will show you that life is to be
lived not just when you're young not
middle-aged the whole thing is to be
lived I have you know
I got to do a podcast with him and that
guy's energy he has the energy of a 22y
old he has the excitement of it and it's
I'm telling you it Beyond being blown
away at how great he still
sounds Beyond being blown away about all
of these songs that he wrote that you
didn't even know that he wrote he wrote
them for other
people um beyond all of that what's
going to make you feel great is that
like life is to be lived you know I mean
sometimes you got to go see a band and
you start thinking like ah [__] I'm
going to die soon you know looking at
these guys not him he's going to come
out there looking like a million bucks
and he's going to absolutely destroy and
it'll be worth every dime you spend I
cannot recommend him high enough um
highly enough all right so after that I
went up north I forget the name of
this I don't know I forget the name it
was Casino Rama like an hour and a half
hour or so north of
Toronto and uh we went to Tim Horton
that's their Dunkin' Donuts up there we
got an ice coffee and we sat outside
smoking cigars drinking iced coffees bus
driver SM smoking a pipe and people were
just walking in looking at us like Hey
we're coming to see you tonight we you
know shooting the [__] with people
taking pictures laughing busting chops
just had a great time went in one of the
most beautiful showrooms I've ever been
in great time there great people
they were funny man they were like super
super like really nice and polite
uh Canadian people was funny so I had to
get them to kind of loosen up because
they were groaning about things and I'm
like this this is hypotheticals you
don't give a [__] about this come on and
then they loosened up it was it was just
a great time um and then last night I
know I'm going through the whole tour I
hope I'm not boring you here last night
I got to play the football stadium next
to uh
the uh Canton Football Hall of Fame and
we rolled up there this is the the same
[__] family trip I took like 40 years
ago we went to Niagara Falls and we went
to the Canton
Football Hall of Fame and it was funny
too I remember my mother was driving at
one point and we had a capri classic
station wagon with the wire rims the V8
fake wood on the side and it was maroon
man the thing was the [__] and uh cloth
Interior right I love that [__] car I
would have liked it better in the
sedan um you know what's hard about that
car is everybody gets them and they
either put those giant wheels on it or
they lower them they turn them into like
low riders so it's really hard to find
one of those in like original condition
I actually found one in I think in
Syracuse was this faded green but it had
a V6 which really surprised me I didn't
know that they just thought they all
came either with a you know a smaller or
a slightly larg V8 so anyway we go
there me and Nate we go into the uh Hall
of Fame and we just go right to the gift
shop I bought this uh Patriots hat and
then they hooked me up with the old
school Pro Football Hall of Fame logo
sweatshirt that I'm still wearing right
now like a little kid and I went in
there like like going to the Pro
Football Hall of Fame for me is like
when some nerd that watches X-Men goes
the X-Men movies or Marvel [__] goes to
ComicCon all right this is my nerd [__]
you know I actually saw some comedian
did a [__]
hilarious bit always you know so many
great young Comics coming up he did this
hilarious bit about like what you know
how like people that are into comic
books and that [__] get made fun of by
sports fans and we do the exact same
[__] they do like we dress up when we go
to games you're wearing the uniform they
dress like the superheroes he did all of
these par it was
fantastic
um but anyway like this [__] was my this
was my thing man like when I was growing
up I did not study for tests I didn't
read I had football cards and that was
my thing and I just sat there looking at
him not realizing that I was looking at
him like I should have been looking at
like my math flashcards or learning how
to spell or doing something I didn't
instead I sat there and I I still
remember just stupid [__] I it's it just
in my brain Louie kelcher for the San
Diego Chargers had a size 16 quadruple E
I still remember the
cartoon um I still remember DD Lewis was
named after
two
um World War II
generals Dwight
Eisenhower and then I think
uh it was a what the what the [__] was
the other one I'm not good with
generals there was Patton
and then there was the other
one I don't know one of them had a d or
whatever but that's what he was named
after DD Lewis number 50 I still
remember all of that and when you know
the
original guys like I know like
autogram uh the 1950s are hard like
Bobby Lane and that type of stuff but
like once once they get into the 60s I
watched all of those NFL films so I like
I knew like I knew like 80% of the guys
from the 80s for the 60s 7s 80s ' 90s is
where it starts to kind of fade for
me where um I didn't know as many
players because I started doing standup
and I was an adult and I had to figure
out you know how
to pay for
[__] so I couldn't sit there I still
wish that Topps football cards just let
you buy a complete set but they have to
try to make them rare so they have value
but like to me that was you know I feel
like now if you play Fantasy Football
that's the best way to know everybody's
names but like I just couldn't get
enough of it when I was growing up it
was um RC thielman all of these linemen
and [__] names that are just in my
head
um anyway uh so we went through there we
took some great
pictures um I went to the Football Hall
of Fame then I smoked a cigar in the
stands and then I went downstairs and
played drums and then I came out it was
like a make make a wish day for me I
came out and it was cold out it was like
great football weather everyone was
bundled up I had like a Hall of Fame
like pom pom hat on and my new
sweatshirt and
uh I went out there and I came out I
told Nate I said I told Nate Craig I
said don't bring me up all right just
say bill will be out in a minute and I
had him ceue up that great NFL films the
autumn wind is a raider we played the
whole poem in the music and I came
out I had [__] chills and my opening
line when I came out I was like nobody
under the age of 56 understood that
intro
so that was
fantastic and right now I am sitting in
one of my favorite cities in the country
which is Milwaukee Wisconsin
um and two months ago I made sure that I
I booked a time for their unbelievable
steam room here at my favorite Hotel the
Fister I swear to God it's called the
Fister p f i s t r it's a family
name
um and uh it's just unbelievable it's
just like it just keeps gradually
getting hotter and hotter and hotter and
you're in this [__] room and then
they have like you know you set you got
to the key is you got to set up
beforehand um oh look at the Bengals
look at the Bengals by the
way uh the Rattler Kenny RI Ken Riley
who should have been in a long time ago
for the Cincinnati Bengals what a
beautiful pass look at
that beautiful pass man I didn't pick
anything this week how about the Eagles
come on man I got the Eagles they're
showing the Rams oh it's 1714
Eagles is that the final if that's the
final I [__] lost that one
too come on get in there get in there
you [__] [__] I need I can't go
over I went four well I do it every year
one
weekend maybe they covered I didn't see
the final score there son of a
[__]
um
anyway uh when you go in it you the key
is is the overhead shower you got to put
that thing on [__] ice cold because
you stay in the Steam for like a half
hour and it just keeps gradually getting
hotter and hotter as the steam comes in
and also the temperature starts going up
too or maybe because it's the steam I
don't [__]
know um but I came out of there feeling
like a [__] million bucks you
know to sweat everything out of me and
I'm you know I'm going home and uh you
know I got the kids so I go home I don't
smoke cigars that's a [__] lie I
don't smoke around when they're around
there but I'm going to try to uh
take a little time off for the 9
millionth time because I feel like uh I
don't know they've had a hold of me
since the end of July when I went on
that family vacation that's just how it
is I just [__] just [__] gets out of
control Paul verie had the Cincinnati
Bengals and I told him I said I don't
know about those Arizona Cardinals they
keep [__] hanging with
people you know good for him and good
for the Bengals too I [__] love that
team somewhere along the line like I
loved him when I was a
kid um
when they had that old
school helmet that kind of looked like
the Brown's helmet cuz Paul Brown went
down there and they made him write
Bengals so it wouldn't be too confusing
and
uh I used to like Isaac Curtis I loved
and uh he was one of the people by the
way that that was the precursor to the
Mel blunt rule because Paul Brown was
like what's the what's the point of
having a fast receiver if these guys are
just going to hold on to him so it was
like no more holding I think there was
that and then I think when Mel blunt
beat the [__] out of Golden
Richards how do I know the Ser they're
so [__] stupid and I I literally lose
my cell phone 12 times a
day just never going to go with that's
all I did as I just [__] watched NFL
films and looked at football cards and
everything else that you were supposed
to learn in life like I just I I don't
know I have no idea so I'm going back to
LA and I'm going to get myself some
glasses finally I was really of the
belief that like once you get glasses
your eyes just get weak and they get
weaker and then they got you you know
what I mean it's like taking a hit of
[__] crack and uh so I don't know
it's pretty good there's two things I'm
really proud of in my life I've never
bought in glasses got some readers but I
haven't got any glasses no no I did buy
them but I only got them for far away I
didn't realize up close I was also
[__] up so I did buy I'll tell you
what I'm proud of I'm 55 years old I'm a
55-year-old bald white man and I've I've
yet to buy a set of golf
clubs I think that that is an
accomplishment because every time that
game starts to get
me because it it's just a game right
it's not a [__] sport it's an
activity it's an a you know whatever
it's adult uh miniature golf or whatever
the [__] you want to call it right is
every time it does I'll I'll go on like
uh I don't know I always seem to like
get like these [__] um golf videos on
Instagram and uh you know it's because
it's the whole [__] guys guy cigars
and all of that so it's sort of my
wheelhouse I will just see some
guy like absolutely
livid there's a guy hits the ball he's
just like [__] godamn DN hate this
[__] [__] [__]
[__]
game
right and he's like [__] he yelled that
at the camera and I'm just sitting there
going like there is no
other
like there's no other game like
that even like say like like pool pool
isn't a sport I kind of put pool bowling
golf where it's like this it is this
muscle memory thing but it's not like
you don't have to catch you don't have
to you don't to throw a [__]
ball and I guess you're rolling it and
bowling I don't all you got to do is
just look at the [__] people that are
playing it all right you can be an
absolute [__] physical mess and be
the best [__] pool player in the
world the best [__]
golfer the best bowler
right [__] die of a heart attack in
the prime of your goddamn career from
like eating they all look like they're
sitting on a [__] couch so many of
them right but all of those things
and all the four major sports and all of
that like I never see somebody playing
hockey and saying like I hate this
[__] game I don't see people playing
football saying that I just I never see
that but those [__]
ones but golf is the one the number one
where someone says I [__] hate this
game and I'm just going like you know I
got enough [__]
issues there's enough [__] that drives
me nuts
traffic morons
you know [__] a group of women all
talking at the same time in a restaurant
enough of that can get me going I don't
need to add [__] golf to it right I
need to do [__] that makes me [__]
chill
um like Aviation makes me [__] chill
occasionally it scares the [__] out of
me but that's part of the game right but
like it makes me [__] chill playing
drums makes me chill driving around you
know in my car or a truck or something
like that I I I I like doing getting a
cup of coffee I'm already like I do
those things because I'm so [__] up
right like I don't need to add the golf
thing what happens with golf is I like
to hang and you know not this last time
I played like [__] the last time but the
time before that I actually played
really good it just feels so good to
[__] just do what you wanted to do
with the
ball um hit it a mile and it's going at
least for me half a mile and it's going
straight but I always just something
about me just always says like you know
what don't [__] do that don't do that
you know what I mean it's kind of like
my brain when I used to be drinking and
like there was certain times when I just
like you know there's certain things you
don't you don't want to [__] start
drinking you know what I mean like if
you're like a neighborhood
party right and there's parents there
and your there's your kids there and
their kids are there that's not one you
don't drink drink then you don't drink
that's not a good time to start drinking
you don't want to get into argument with
another parent or just like there's just
too many you don't want to be you know
bump into somebody's kid or not notice
that your kid fell into a pool you got
to be on your game there it's sort of
like afterward oh come on Kelsey get
back in the game I don't want to see
this guy get hurt all right there he is
all right he's back there we
go so
um any anyway I keep getting that
[__] video where whatever the name of
that woman is that he's dating I I know
I know it I just can't for some reason I
can't pull it
up um Taylor Swift
bang Taylor Swift watching her [__]
fans
losing their
minds when her songs come on it's one of
my favorite [__] things ever you know
and I hate all these old people going
like dude what the [__] is wrong with
you what do you mean what the [__] is is
wrong with these
people it's part of being young
everybody you know you need your rock
stars you need your comedians they need
their movies just let them be young
they're gonna laugh at it someday but
also be like choked up because that's
like their whole [__] Universe I
[__] hate old people that do [__]
like that I've been guilty of it you
know ruining young people's good [__]
times so good for them good for them
losing their [__] minds you know I'm
going to sit there and be like what the
[__] with them and I'm all excited to
see
ACDC they're going out for the 50th
[__] year in a row almost and I'm I'm
G to go see him you
know you can't be an [__] right well
you can be that's one of the easiest
things to be as a [__] [__] and
God knows I'm good at it um all right
well I don't have my reads right now so
I'm just going to say that I have the
reads and then we'll just edit them in
all right now let's let's do the reads
for this week all right coming out of
the reads
here
um let's see Niagara show and carool
Lanes oh yeah I did a I did when I was
doing my show my show um I was talking
about HOV
lanes and I was explaining them because
I was in Canada and I found when I was
going through Europe you know people
it's not like they don't know what it it
is they just maybe they call it
something different the commuter lane or
something like that so I was explaining
to her and this Canadian dude all the
way up top just he's he's like we've had
those for
years made me feel like an [__] what
a [__] lucky throw that
was
underthrown I got the one thing I I
cannot stand is these self- congratul
congratulations that people do every
time they make a [__] catch thump in
their chest acting like that they're
going to war you're not you're not
[__] that wasn't underthrown that was
perfect
he's [__] tapping himself on top of
the head yeah yeah I'm [__]
amazing yeah why don't why don't you
[__] do that when you drop a pass
nodding their [__] head
vigorously so [__] dumb and the only
reason why they're doing that is because
they see other people doing it so then
they think that that's what they should
be
doing
um I never saw Jerry Rice do that he
just caught the [__] ball and you
couldn't catch him and then that was it
I didn't have to [__] watch him be in
awe of himself but I'm doing that right
he Taylor Swift don't be a dick Bill all
right yeah be amazed with yourself all
right so Niagara show and carpool LS hey
Bill just saw your show at the OGG stage
in Niagara Falls Canada great show as
always saw you last year in Toronto by
the way a lot of us Canadians are Bruins
fans Not the maple Maple laughs oh
because I was talking about them I
thought you'd be maybe saber fans before
Leaf I mean uh Bruins fans uh I can
relate to your story about the HOV lane
I was in uh California on a baseball
road trip back in
2012 after San Diego La in Anaheim
headed north for San Francisco and
Oakland oh that's cool look at that
you're going to see all the
ballparks uh San Francisco and Oakland
games I left La at 900
a.m. the PCH was a nightmare
construction and
accidents I was dying to get to the
hotel in San Francisco for a shower and
a meal as you know the HOV lanes are
time specific in most areas do they have
one on on the PCH I thought you had to
be on the
five uh 7:45 a.m. and 3:45 to 4:45 p.m.
for rush hour it was about 4:30 and I
said I was spent so I figured what the
hell another 15 minutes won't hurt about
3 minutes into the sailing past backed
up traffic I saw the CHP cherries in my
rear view mirror busted the cop asked me
do you know why I pulled you over I was
like ah yeah when he saw my registration
rental California and my Ontario
driver's license I explained that my
vacation
destinations uh told him I had left La
at 9 and I was beat tired and figured
another 15 minutes wouldn't be a problem
he laughed and no ticket for driving in
the HOV lane there you
go right now people of color listening
to this are like you can [__] do that
yes you can that's another one of the
things we can do if you just admit it
and you make them laugh sometimes they
let you go
um I did that one time when I [__] I
made an illegal
U-turn uh and then [__] went into a
Post
Office right in front of this
cop and he pulled me over he goes you
know why I pulled you over and I said
yeah he goes why I go because I made an
illegal U-turn over a double yellow line
in front of
traffic and he goes why did you do that
I said because I'm impatient and
sometimes I have a sense of
entitlement he
[__] he laughed no he didn't laugh
that guy didn't
laugh the [__] did he say oh so long ago
what the [__] did he say I said I'm
impatient and I have a sense of
entitlement he goes didn't you see me
there that's what he said didn't you see
me there and I said yeah and he said
well then why did you do that I said
because you weren't faced at me it was
the back of your car and I thought you
know maybe I could get away with it I'm
impatient I have a sense of
entitlement oh what you know I'm going
to give you a ticket or I can't remember
what he said he said well I'm not going
to write you up cuz I have to go
somewhere and I said you're awesome and
that's when he laughed he said don't do
that again I said all right and you know
what I didn't that can happen sometimes
but that's the best way to go when the
cops pull you over oh you know they know
you're [__] lying don't lie just be
like yeah I'm a [__] [__] do you
know why he pulled me over yeah cuz I'm
an impatient [__] that made an
illegal U-turn right in front of you
over a double
line it's much better than being like no
I I I thought I thought I could cut
across four lanes of [__] traffic and
what all right bellich is a me is
mediocre at
best yeah this is
um this is like one of these things
where like the amount of people that
watch sports all the time and they just
still don't even understand
Sports this is like is he is he really
mediocre at best he like dominated the
league for 20 years as everyone was
stealing from him while everyone was say
oh he did this and he did that and blah
blah blah and meanwhile all they were
doing was watching game film stealing
from him and what usually H that happens
to every great coach and what usually
happens is because they steal from you
literally meaning offering ridiculous
amounts of money to your players and all
your coaching staff and you're
constantly rebuilding and then you have
to like if you don't change up what you
do your little run will last at best
three or four years instead his lasted
for 20
years okay he went to nine Super Bowls
he won nine AFC championships and he won
six Super
Bowls I mean now the guys watch now he's
overrated because now now you know when
our [__] Joe Montana leaves we didn't
have a Steve Young to fill in so now
you're going to say the guy
sucks um all right hey Billy Boston can
you please stop referring to bill bich
in such positive words as a genius and
the greatest of all time that's not what
I said I said he's the second coming of
Paul Brown and he is and if you knew
your football history that's 100% right
Paul Brown dominated the league for 20
years as did Bill bellich both of them
changed the game I mean bill bellich was
so [__] dominant the [__] Colts
had to get their owner on the
competition committee they literally
made how we covered their receivers
illegal and then they stole our
offense and beat the Bears in the Super
Bowl finally got past us and beat
[__] Rex grman and the bears in the
Super Bowl all
right I said that to a Baltimore to an
Indianapolis Colts and he put his head
down and [__] laughed they know it's
[__] true so don't even start with
this [__] [__] he's the product
of a lucky guess oh so he just luckily
guessed okay he's a product of a lucky
guest on a late draft pick who turned
out to be the greatest quarterback of
all time so it's not him at all oh yeah
I could have coached him anybody could
have anybody you could take any any any
of these [__] bum ass head coaches
that [__] come into the league if
they get the [__] out of here without
Brady he's clearly just another mediocre
head coach no he isn't you're you're a
[__] [__] you're just I I don't want
to [__] I [__] hate when people do
this
okay it's like the quarterback needs the
head coach and the head coach needs the
quarterback and don't act like [__]
Tom Brady went to a [__] weak team
down in Tampa all of those weapons that
he had he [__] hand selected that
[__] Team all right the [__] out of
here but what no whatever I get it if
you want to go that way yeah you're a
[__] um without Brady he's clearly just
another mediocre head coach I mean how
long was he supposed to dominate for you
know what was funny early in Brady's
career everyone was saying Brady stunk
and that he was a system quarterback
it's just a system you could plug
anybody in there that's what they said
and then we started winning and then
they said they're cheating and now that
he's not good now they're saying he's
just a [__] mediocre coach I got to
tell you something right now you guys
non- Patriot fans you haters are the
biggest [__] bunch of whiny [__]
I've ever met in my [__] life when
the Steelers were dominating I was like
they're a great [__] team when the
Cowboys then had their run I was like
when the 49ers I never sat they oh
they're [__] cheating oh Bill Walsh
is actually [__] overrated he's
nothing without Joe Montana no they're
all [__] great they're all [__]
great and you know what whoever wrote
this [__] you know what you haven't
found out what you're great at yet you
know what you're great at hating at PE
hating on people that are [__]
successful there is not one [__]
person in the
NFL who's going to agree with you on
this is like listening to young people
saying the Beatles are overrated there's
not one [__] musician out there
that's going to say that they're [__]
overrated they're not okay it's just it
is what it is you just don't get it and
and that's all it is anyway here we go
without Brady he's clearly just another
mediocre Brady goes to Buccaneers as a
gentleman's move to prove it is him and
not bellich that is the reason for the
Rings oh yeah did Tom Brady call you up
and that's what he
said is that what he said he goes and
does it Goat move and I hate Brady oh
this is one of these things where you
[__] trash Joe Biden and then you go
and I'm a liberal uh but the numbers do
not lie I cannot think of any possible
way you can prove
otherwise um okay well I I I don't
understand what you just proved there
other than that you that all you do is
watch the ball you're a ball Watcher I
remember hearing like the worst Sports
shows the wor there's a lot of them too
the worst Sports shows all had this take
that when Brady left and went to um
the Tampa Bay uh
Buccaneers and succeeded they were like
well then was it Tom BR to that [__]
take what you guys seem to
forget is that when Tom Brady lost all
of his options at wide receiver we
became a mediocre team while he was
still here then we had Cam Newton Cam
Newton didn't have any luck M Jones has
not been having any luck we H we haven't
replaced the Edelman the West
Welker um um amond doas we just haven't
had
anybody for them to throw to and then
all of a sudden Tom Brady looked pretty
[__] beatable Tom Brady and the
Patriots were pretty [__] beatable
his last year there but you're going to
[__] ignore that and then he goes to
a loaded Buccaneers team I wouldn't say
loaded but like had an Brady W first of
all Brady won and bellich won with way
[__] less here's something else you
dumb [__]
if you knew your [__] history you're
sitting there thinking that bill bellich
only has six rings how about this he has
eight Rings how about this bill parcel's
never won a Super Bowl without bill
bellich as his defensive coordinator how
about this he shut down three of the
greatest [__] offenses of all [__]
time how about this he [__] owned
pton Manning and that three-headed
monster until they had to [__]
cheat okay one of the most Che ass [__]
ass [__] franchises out there the
Indianapolis Colts who I don't know how
a team owner being on the competition
committee is [__]
legal all right he shut down John Elway
and that high-powered Fun Bunch uh
offense Giants win in 86 he shut down
the Run and Gun Jim Kelly and all of
those he shut them down and then the
greatest show on
Turf before when we played the [__]
Rams he did that with he coached a
backup [__]
quarterback who was a six round draft
pick to beating what everyone was saying
was the beginning of a dynasty what
you're doing is you're
forgetting you are [__]
forgetting all of those early ones and
that was Bill
bellich and we would [__] take away
and everything that he did he stopped
all of those guys he's the one of the
greatest defensive Minds that ever
[__]
existed and he was able to do do it in
the 70s 80s '90s 2000
2000s W eight Super Bowl rings he's
almost out of fingers you [__]
[__] how did parcel's do without
him
huh how did he do the [__] out of here
so is Bill parcel's overrated because I
don't think he
is I don't think he is so I think you're
is a [__] take and I think because as
you sign your thing that you're a
[__] Dolphins
fan signed a [__] Dolphins fan yeah
you're just [__] butt hurt because
you [__] [__] haven't won a Super
Bowl in 50 years and all that you have
every year is being excited that
somebody doesn't go
undefeated that's how pathetic your
[__] franchise
is you know and you completely ignore
that back in the day day there was no
ESPN you went undefeated when there was
only 14 regular season games and you had
two white running backs the [__] out of
here that
[__]
[__] um that is the worst take ever
uh you are a [__]
[__] um you really are
dumb that one one of the worst takes
I've ever heard in my life Tom Brady is
the greatest [__] quarterback is far
is like how long he did it you know but
here's another thing too I would never
say that that Brady is better than Dan
Marino you know Dan Marino had Don
Schuler but Don schula was not like Bill
bich where people caught up to him
people caught up to him and then passed
him and the game passed him by that did
not happen to
belich for for like 50 [__] years
this guy has been crushing it but
whatever we have two three bad [__]
seasons and now you're gonna flush all
that down the [__]
toilet dude Dan Marino had no running
game his whole career and he had no
[__] defense and his 1984 season when
you could beat the [__] out of a
quarterback those numbers are the are
Wayne Gretzky level [__] numbers and
I would never sit here I would never say
that
like that he was better than
uh than Brady I wouldn't I wouldn't say
that Brady's better than Joe Montana I
think there is no greatest of all time
but for you to like go out and
accomplish great things and then for you
to wait for a couple of week Seasons
everybody had bad drafts what about
Chuck null what about towards the end of
his career when how ridiculously
beatable the Pittsburgh Steelers became
do you give all the credit to to Terry
Bradshaw is Chuck no's
[__] three years unbelievable drafts
in a
row is is that all [__] because at
the end of his [__] career he wasn't
winning get the [__] out of here you sir
are a [__] jerk
off all right with that I'm gonna go get
some [__] dinner I'm gonna go do my
show and I'll finish this [__]
later oh geez I'm back here just when I
thought that [__]
[__] he probably just wrote that bill
bich stuff just to listen to me lose my
mind there's no way anybody is that
stupid you know he's also probably that
Dolphins fan was the entire when early
in Brady's career was saying he was a
system quarterback then he said he was a
cheater and it's just like just no it I
get it you hate the Patriots that's all
you're [__] saying all right um and I
bet those awful Sports talk shows the
reason why they were saying [__] about
Bill bich is because you know they
commercial fish so they need to get the
mouth breathing more
on [__] sports fan H you know what
that one of the things that I hate the
most
about um
Sports is that athletes get old and
coaches get old and all of that stuff
and then when that happens all the
jealous people all the haters all the
[__] Sports writers they relish it
they relish an old Brett Favre and old
Muhammad Ali they were so [__] bad to
Muhammad Ali so racist to Muhammad Ali
and then once he got like [__]
Parkinson's and all of that then all of
a sudden they were super nice to him and
[__] but like when they're in the prime
of their career it's just so many people
are so [__] unhappy with their lives
that they can't they just can't
appreciate greatness you know like
whatever you're doing down there in
Florida why don't why don't you [__]
you know be inspired by what bill bich
has accomplished rather than trying to
rip the guy down when he's in his
[__]
70s and you know I working on his like I
don't know what trying trying to win his
[__] ninth
ring um that's a weak [__] move and I
think it says a lot about
yourself um oh I went I went extra on
that one [__] irritated the [__] out
of
me [__] idiots
um the guy's like just basically been
getting [__] on his entire [__]
career it's just it's just what it is it
is what it is
he can't win without
Parcels uh he's [__] you know he got
lucky with Tom Brady he's [__]
cheating the gays passed him by
meanwhile he's the most [__]
successful guy in the longest run in the
modern times but yeah he's overrated
okay all right there hey good luck
winning a Super Bowl um Miami Dolphins
and you look great this year I'm not
going to [__] on on the Dolphins cuz I
actually I love him this year I love him
playing spoiler and nobody even brought
him up it was all about the bills and
the Jets and here they come so I am
enjoying that but I do have to say that
it's been a really weak thing that every
year you know not only okay you want to
[__] pop the champagne in private
okay but the fact that they do it
publicly you know what I mean and they
take enjoyment in other people's
failures I always just thought that was
such a weak [__] move that be like me
I'm an old comic now I don't root
against younger
comedians don't have a better special
than me um American
tourists hey Billy too kind uh your take
on American Tourist a few weeks ago was
a bit a bit
self-hating Catholic guilt
driven how do you feel that oh because I
trash the Catholic church and you still
like jar uh I've been a tour guide and a
server to tourist in two European
countries and American tourists are by
far the most generous and friendly
what's because we come from a Tipp in
culture
uh for starters no one can tip like
Americans yeah call it a cultural thing
it is they don't pay waiters in our
country um but e hey when they get AI
[__] waiters do we have to tip them
I'll call it a cultural thing but even
when they know it's not expected they do
so it would be the difference of me
making enough money to pay my rent or
not on some days when an American would
throw down 50 or three on a 300 EUR
meal uh as that as giving
AA as fact did you mean in fact giving a
care about me and who I am as a human
being no other country tourist actually
take interest in me as a person dude we
don't give a [__] about you as a person
okay get over yourself we it's a part of
the meal is tipping it's just what we do
you know what I mean it's like it's like
English people they're going to have a
[__] pint and if the beer you can see
through it they're going to say it's
weak piss and they're going to send it
back it's they're not being rude it's
just what they do uh I'm not saying it
never happened but never in the numbers
the the
Americans did okay this is a little
jumpy all right so you saying we're not
as bad as we are all right well I didn't
think we were that bad I was just
[__] being self-deprecating I don't
think it's Catholic
guilt I can't remember the last time I
went to church or even believed in
anything those [__] murderous rapist
lunatics had to say why would I give a
[__] about their rules at this point um
all right Bill
relax um when I gave tours they would
ask questions about me and my story that
were relevant and not just pandering
polite I won't name the countries that
looked at me like I was some object to
be there for them in any way they needed
I can take a few guesses also when it
comes to their children Americans are
far more aware of what their kids are
doing and how they are acting unlike the
Scandinavian countries who just let
their kids scream and do whatever they
want now see I never saw that when I was
in Scandinavia I will say I got dirty
looks with my kids from an English
couple when I was in
France uh also Americans don't light up
cigarettes anywhere they want and adhere
to the local culture and rules far more
than most
countries all right well maybe we're
coming around take it easy on your
people bill they got me through
University and I am forever grateful for
their kindness well
maybe you're meeting the the the top
ones cuz I'm not going to lie we're
[__] animals over here man that's why
we're funny we're animals the English
are animals the Irish the Scottish the
[__] Australians as far as white
people we we're [__]
lunatics lunatics abuse alcohol getting
arguments we're
funny we [__] lunatics I would not
call us
refined um
all right I already read this one
bellich is mediocre at best all
right um all right drummer drummers Here
song for first time oh I've I've watched
these These are really interesting um
all right hey there Billy
Scrat Billy scrum scr o t is that
supposed to be like Bon Scott T that
should have been Bill Billy Bon Scott
scrotum Billy bun scrotum I think that
that's what I like that one uh I
stumbled upon this absolute Gem of Chad
Smith drumming to a song he's never
heard before this is a series on YouTube
you know what I watch that I it's a
really popular song too I love that he
had never heard it like you know I'm an
old guy I don't [__] know what these
kids are listening to uh this is a
series on YouTube but most drummers
listen to the song three or four times
and take notes before trying to play
along along to it Chad Dives right in
not even giving it one full listen
though and it's incredible
anyways I thought you would enjoy this
as much as I do might be too long to
play on the podcast but give it a listen
and let me know uh your thoughts for
next week yeah dude Chad Smith has been
playing
live I mean I would think he was doing
it before he got in the chili peppers
and he got in them in the
89 I mean that's 34 35 years ago I think
after a
while
um it's just like breathing you know
I've seen that guy play live a number of
times and uh what strikes me most about
him is the high intensity
level that he plays at for the
entire the entire
show um he is definitely the engine
that's running that band man he's he's
an incredible drummer so um I watched a
couple of those I watched like a
um I don't know this black drummer right
I was going to say an R&B drummer I'm
not going to assume that that's what he
plays but he was like listening to some
like Metallica song or something like
that and there was like time signature
changes and [__] it might have been
something off Injustice for all and he
made a couple of notes oh okay uh oh oh
that's in five and he just like like
nothing like he was listening to a
language
and he and he went and murdered it and
threw all this extra stuff in there I
don't think it was Metallica but it was
definitely something not
like um it was definitely in the metal
Arena and not mainstream either it was
really cool um all right youf days this
is all [__] drum stuff I love it um
hey Bill first firstly I've been
following your standup as well as your
podcast for a few years now after
hearing you on Joe Rogan you make me
smile laugh and thank thank so thank you
look at
that old Billy Dr Seuss over here um I
to I took my 13-year-old son to see the
youf days experience oh man he must have
that must have blown his mind uh last
night in Bristol England Jesus he and
his band are incredible live yeah I so
happy I got to uh I got to see them in
New York man um really really incredible
band and like exciting cuz you can see
like it's like 80% they know what
they're doing and then there's 20%
looking at each other in each song I
Feel improvising and stuff which really
makes it I don't know I don't know how
they I don't know how they do that [__]
it's amazing anyway we had to use my
son's older brother's birth certificate
to get him in the venue had an age
restriction all right the security guard
asked my son his name and date of birth
and he gave his brother's detail without
batting an eyelid you must have been
proud and also nervous uh my sphincter
tightened as the huge security guard
asked his questions and my boy was as
cool as a [__] cucumber I may have
trouble telling when he's trying to pull
the wool over my eyes in the future yeah
and you just got him to pass a big test
so unless you're 300 lbs I think he's
going to be walking all over you uh we
watched from the front of the crowd as
Yousef and his band tore it up my son's
drum drums a bit my son drums a bit he
likes to play but hasn't been interested
in lessons last night as our heads
bobbed in unison I could literally see
the uh Petals of his mind open up and
them get blown away by what he sat and
watched pretty [__] special dude
that's
awesome if you took him to that show
imagine that and it inspires him maybe
starts playing drums and next thing you
know you're watching him up on that same
stage it's pretty cool anyway the person
says my question is have you taken your
kids to many gigs if so what and how did
they get on if not what would be the
artist you'd like to introduce your kids
via live music
um I have not taken my kids to a concert
they're six and three my wife has taken
my daughter to go see uh Beyonce which
you know I was telling her I was like
wow that's really cool and I was like
you
know is an unbelievable responsibility
really somebody's first concert cuz
that's the question people always ask
what was the first concert you ever saw
and uh for her to say Beyonce is
amazing you know what's cool my mother
you know what her first concert she ever
saw was she saw Elvis Presley right
before he did he did Ed Sullivan so he
wasn't even famous she was somewhere in
like Sarasota Florida I've told this
story before she saw a matina show in a
half filled
theater and I remember asking I was
going were the women screaming the you
know the teenagers screaming when he was
up there or they just like who is this
weirdo guy she goes no they were all
screaming going crazy I go were you
doing that too and she was like no I was
sort
of observing was observing what was
going on with so my mom you
[Laughter]
know she comes to my show she sits there
and she [__] she doesn't laugh she's
looking at other people to see their
reaction like that's I don't know it's
just how she's wired it's funny so
um I'm definitely going to take uh my
kids to concerts and stuff um both my
kids love playing on my drum set and
everything and um you know I I bought
that big kit where I got you know it's
two up three down you know I never set
them up like that I usually just set
them up just one up two down but I have
I can go bigger or smaller with the
drums I have
so you know my kids have really taken to
playing drums so I was like
well I have enough racks you know to
uh get another kit here and I have a
couple extra snare drums why don't I
just buy another bass drums that's what
I did I just bought a small 20 and I'm
going to put that together and just have
them you
know my kit and the kid's kit facing
each other someday if we can play like
some groes and trade fours and stuff
that would be
unbelievable um really looking forward
to that and at the same time not forcing
them to do it like my son's always like
like Dad da boom boom B play boom boom
bap he's kind of getting bigger now so
now he's saying uh thata play drums I do
miss boom boom bap though it was so
freaking cute and when he plays he like
dances he does like this shoulder roll
thing as he's playing and um my daughter
has a different style it's funny what
they gravitate towards like my daughter
really liked the symbols and my son
really like the
drums um and then they watch each other
play and then they sort of get ideas
from each other and I just sit there
totally geeking out as a dad it's
awesome all right that's it
okay well uh right so I guess it's going
to be a long season for me as a Patriots
fan um but that's I'm not [__] whine
about it I mean I
saw unbelievable successes and I've been
here before as a Patriots fan the people
are going to have a problem or kids who
are like under 30 like wait the Patriots
lose yeah that's that's how it used to
be so um we shall see how that goes uh
the Eagles won so that covers so now I'm
one and two I just need the Jets to hold
on uh and I and I'll go two and two once
again that would be cool at this point
considering I started off 0 and2 all
right that's it go [__] yourselves thank
you from the bottom of my heart to
everybody who came out to all of these
shows from Portland Maine Manchester New
Hampshire Hampshire
Springfield Syracuse Penn State Niagara
North of
Toronto uh Canton Ohio thank you to
everybody at the hall of fame how great
they treated us thank you to The Crew
putting the stage together I know
tonight was like a big deal where they
had a basketball game and they had to
wait till that was done and then they
were going to load it in so they've been
busting their ass for me and thank you
to everybody in Milwaukee and the City
of Milwaukee you know I love this place
uh that's it go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on
Thursday